thank you did you enjoy seeing this on
the screen again get your yeah unfilmed
the way you made it he's showing on film
the way you made it so I have a few
questions one is Hector and the credits
mentioned Burt Lancaster so my question
for you is was bird ever seriously
considered to star in this film and what
was that process of his involvement
because I think that's kind of an
unusual circumstance that most people
seem thinking of this film today would
not be aware of well for the first
fourteen months of the project's
evolution Burt Lancaster was the Sun the
solar system everything was revolving
around him it was not it was a
contentious relationship he did not like
he loved the novel he did not accept the
the screenplay he'd considered Leonard
Schrader to be a typist and around seven
months into the 14 month stretch he
proposed a solution he was going to
bring an assistant from Rome who could
take notes for him so he could express
what everything that we're doing wrong
and those notes evolved into the Burt
Lancaster script and it was delivered I
had no idea that he was writing a script
it was delivered in April of 1988 82 83
and Hector happened to be in town and we
met at Leonard's house and I had to
translate the script into Portuguese for
him and
we got about 30 pages in and all I could
remember of that evening was that I've
never laughed so hard about what's on
the floor we were all gagging when
laughs it's one of those it's you know
it's something out of like like a movie
scene you know we cannot stop laughing
but we also were crying at the same time
because we knew the game was over and I
think Bert was a passive-aggressive
person he was very forceful but there
was a soft side to him and he he
expected that we would come and kiss his
hand like milena kissed the wardens and
oh thank god Bert you've shown us the
way well we didn't do that he just left
us cold and we never heard from the
camera but was he considering playing
one of the characters he was we were
developing the project for him as Molina
he was Molina it's very interesting did
you mention yes because there was an in
on my birthday in March a month before I
get a phone call from a man whose name I
did not know it was an agent in New York
his he was partners was a two-man agency
kind of with partner desks with a guy
named Jeff hunter who I was ducking
because Jeff hunter was Rollo Julia's
agent and he had been haranguing me give
me a date give me a date Raul's got a
baby coming he's got at work you'll have
to if we're not doing this film he's got
to take he's got to take a play but he's
you have to have to commit
well can I commit we're waiting for Burt
right and so I was always ducking Jeff
Hunter's calls and I took this call from
his partner without realizing it and he
says he identifies who he is and and he
said just read Leonard Schrader script
and it's the best screenplay I've read
in 10 years in which you consider
William Hurt so I'm thinking to myself
you know I'm not very experienced at
that time
wow these agents are amazing he's I
think he's talking about who William
Hurt for the political prisoner which is
Raul Julia's role and I thought he was
knifing his partner's client in the back
and
got through that and he's a known for
blood but that's per Lancaster he's yes
I know his name was Jean per se Jim you
just passed away actually in March yes I
know but if anything happens to Burt
Lancaster would you please consider
William Hurt okay
and I think William Hurt was actually
quite new and hot at that time he was
very hot altered states Gorky Park was
he was actually at that time he was
doing posts in Gorky Park and a body
heat body he was in altered states and
then one or two other films but he was
like he was like the thinking man's new
brand is it kind of like the new brand
oh they kind of yuppie Brando with them
yes but also a very much a leading man
very much a leading man very much every
studio wanted him for something I mean
he was like known as you're right and so
I caught so when we got the Burt
Lancaster script of a there's six weeks
later I call up gene par Sagan and I
said well you're you've heard that we've
lost Berlin yes he says would you I said
I said well you serious about William
Hurt he says of course I said has
William wet read the script no I want
you to tell me if you want me to give it
to him I said yes I do well does Hector
want him I said of course he does Hector
thought it was John Hurt man yeah baby
book he stopped Alonzo Dave no I'm
serious and he was he was right oh that
would have been interesting too
yeah sure but he just to finish this
anecdote ten years after let's say ten
years ago long after the film was
finished I'm speaking the gene was the
dear person and I said and somehow I he
told me what happened when he sent
William Hurt the script in London where
he was doing post on Gorky he called him
up they called gene up in the middle of
the night he was in the
created and said well I've read 25 pages
what do you think and Jean parsegian
said well it'll destroy your career get
you your Oscar well what are you waiting
for sign me up and the rest is history
I guess so well Jean and you have B both
have Jean to thank them oh my god so
talk a little bit you mentioned the
straighter script you mentioned this
Burt Lancaster script and of course this
is based on you know a novel and that
had it been turned into a play before
yes yes in fact in fact it was a two-man
stage play minimum you know kind of like
minimums no set nothing it could be done
anywhere and Manuel would put it on
himself in various european capitals
there's all evolution to it but the
short story is that you he would
basically promote the novel this way and
it was very popular stage play in Europe
okay and it was a plague all over South
America and so Manuel was traveling
constantly going to you know introduced
to play and so forth so yeah it was a
stage fight and but Manuel worked on it
with Leonard a little or was well aware
that's I don't know how much how much
time you want to spend on that let me
just make it simple there were what we
call in you know I did a documentary
called tangled web yes and into end
tangled web I kind of do a graphic which
basically gets this idea across
there were dueling screen pay plays
there a for screenplays going on at once
there was a Hector promise Manuel that
he could have his first draft so Manuel
was writing his basically was an
extended stage play Hector had also
promised the writer who had done P shut
for him that he would write this creep
mm-hmm one wasn't so that one wasn't was
in Portuguese one when well Manuel was
writing was in what they called ports an
y'all it was kind of like a border
border lingo between Brazil and Spanish
Portuguese and Spanish
Leonard was writing his I mean he was
the workhorse and Bert was writing his
and no one there was no the twain did
not meet finally it was Bert it was it
was Leonard script and
Manuel was well that's that's the long
story about evolution but in in a
nutshell
but Hector was a happy with it Hector
yes with leonard script yeah Hector
wanted results okay yeah and yeah Manuel
and Leonard as I mentioned were
remarkably alike like the characters
they had they were writing and so they
had a long struggle but eventually they
came to understand appreciate and really
care for each other a lot so that was
that type of an evolutionary process and
the beginning Leonard was extremely you
know kind of like he was very tightly
wound person very quiet but tightly
wound and he would he was worried that
we would you know the traditional
novelist plaint of the screenwriter
ruining his material so he lived with
that kind of fear he used to do numbers
but now I think I got weak about 25 to
30 percent on my side if I could get him
up to fifty I'll be satisfied would run
numbers on I'm pleased satisfaction so I
my memory may be a little off on dates
and stuff but you were starting this in
like 80 to 82 January 82 it's remarkably
quick and 82 and 83 there really wasn't
any great knowledge about what became
the AIDS epidemic right it's really
heard of it yet or it was just started
well let me tell you it let me tell you
the whopper yeah
the whopper is that on July I'm gonna
pick a date July 28th whatever was that
Friday that the film opened in cinema
one in New York across from
bloomingdales this is two months after
Con so it was like wham I was like a
tsunami that morning that Friday morning
every single newspaper and this is
before internet so there's only
newspapers right every single newspaper
American care America carried the same
headline Rock Hudson dying right and I
was in a state of shock because there
were people there were Jewish mothers
lining up
at nine o'clock in the morning with
their Bloomingdale shopping bags gabbing
amongst themselves for the 12 o'clock
show they were lining up three hours in
the morning early worried about their
day sons they're everyone's you know
living in complete you know terror what
is this all about the gate cancer mm-hmm
and it was it was as my definition of
zeitgeist it was the zeitgeist UK Molina
is a the character of Molina is a gay
martyr Rock Rock Hudson was whatever
mm-hmm we want to label that as he was
you know at a complex life and it was
just in the air well but at the same
time the idea of any I mean
homosexuality and all of it was not at
all accepted Oh completely non
especially someone as effeminate as the
Molina character correct and the kind of
the you know the logline of the you know
the you had a marketing line so this was
it was like the ultimate anti marketing
line it was a [ __ ] in a commie in a jail
so who do you who do you hate worse who
do you not relate to more like Fagin
economy right so was that what were the
challenges of trying to make this movie
and and actually get it released and get
it with was that something that you came
across on a regular basis as far as
distribution or even financing people
saying this film was financed by art
collectors Friends of a print friends of
mine friends of Hector's there was not a
cent of industry money in it I have a
wonderful collection of rejection
letters because the script had an
incredible punch to it I had incredible
power people it would people like you
know in the industry me names that you
know I mean they were astonished by the
we couldn't touch it this is an amazing
of course I can right right so there was
no chance in the world that would ever
have distribution we made it because we
had friends who you know it's like
having a rich uncle or something you
know friends who thought okay alright
here's the you know go ahead do your
heart
you know so you managed to get one of
the hottest box office stars and at the
same time you have this incredibly
difficult material and you have a very
challenging rule for that star but then
at the same time to make things even
more box office challenging you shoot in
San Paulo and have this whole kind of
political context of the film so could
you talk about shooting down there and
what that well yeah the shooting
yourself Paulo was very strange it was I
was supposed to be a 60-day schedule
which is like a long schedule but it
went to a hundred and four so Wow yeah
and burned through all the money that
I'd put aside my piggy bank for the post
but you know that's the next step right
but what was interesting to me I had
been an old Brazil hand I speak the
language and I've been going there since
I was a kid actually and this was the
last of I believe six or no eight
generals
it was military dictatorship I was
actually there in 1964 when the CIA coup
overthrew the government and there was a
series of generals from the southernmost
state like Texas Texas generals okay and
the last one was Ron Figueiredo and he
was still president and when we when we
when we were shooting and there was a
feeling that at any moment we could be
shut down and put away because we're
making a film about a military
dictatorship at that waning last moments
of a will military dictatorship and no
one noticed Wow yeah so how long this
had a little bit of a long gestation
period as far as editing is concerned
well it's somehow the the the number
fourteen months reoccurs fourteen months
is it actually it went very quickly in
in film you know in kind of like
development hell terms it was 14 months
from January
genrih 82 till burt lancaster script
came in in april that was 14 months and
i was 14 months in editing now in the 35
millimeter universe you know if you're
if you're editing for two months okay
when are you gonna finish when you get
into the third month there's something's
wrong when you get into the fifth month
this movie's never gonna see the light
of day there's a wonderful moment that
happened in August of 1984 Hector was
being what's the word pushed by the New
York Film Festival take your pick
opening night closing night whichever
you want we have to have this film why
because you know his his cash a frumpy
shot bill at the New York accurate Raul
is it just towering New York figure both
run Broadway plays rob was doing nine
bill was doing early burly you know on
Broadway so they were you know this was
a this was a hot property for the New
York Film Fest which was in September of
84 so when I go to New York on this hot
August day I'm schlepping the fiber you
know boxes with the interlock you know
thousand-foot real interlock so it was
like six boxes right because there's 17
reels right and the New York Film
Festival you know that crew of Lincoln
Center people you know they saw it at
nine o'clock in the morning and so it's
like at that point the film is running
two hours and forty 15 minutes sometimes
almost an hour longer than what you see
and I go to wait discreetly so that you
know everyone's gone and I go to and I
and I figure I'll wait for the
projectionist to I go there in the boxes
just standing out on the court and the
corner said boy everyone that fats
available they walked out on the third
real laughing their asses
I said you've got to be kidding and it
took me four days to find out the person
who was kind of the interlock a tour for
the New York Film Festival a Brazilian
guy named Fabian Kahn Olson he couldn't
bring himself to tell me that they could
not take this film seriously there was
it was it was a joke and that was the
first screening on that day the next
screening was at a two o'clock in the
afternoon and a schlep it was very hot I
was like I mean I've never sweat so much
slurping you know trying to get a cab
with six boxes of fiberglass and so we
get to the next area now this is Raul
the two agents Jeep are Seguin and Jeff
hunter
Savio Nicole said the Brazilian
interlocutor Glenn Schrader myself and
Bill's gonna watch it himself that night
he wants to wait till after the play you
know he's doing Broadway every night and
he'll rent his own screening room so
three hours later the lights come up in
a screening room on Broadway and what
and raúl juliá is sitting there what
happened to all our great work and gene
parsegian says you've got to do
something to save the movie this is a
catastrophe is going to ruin both their
careers and Jeff hunter was like you
wouldn't even speak to me there was a
third screening bill and Glenn bill and
I were not getting along
he liked Glenn and Bill's lady friend
who another actress in that play they
want they started watching at midnight
and Schrader doesn't come back until the
next day around two o'clock in the
afternoon
what happe I thought you got mud you
know well I had to save the movie Dave I
said what do you mean well your troubles
are over bill wants to buy the negative
he wants to burn it
Wow scrutiny number three right so
meanwhile the next day I get a phone
call from Francisco Hamal was the
production manager executive producer
they call it but in Brazil and he gave
me some very bad news too Hector has
cancer Hector was in he had just gone
back to Brazil
he had a biopsy and exact nose with
non-hodgkins lymphoma this is all
happening one day
so next quest not one not one of your
favorite days I tell you well it's
that's what it was like right so how
long did it take to get the well
interestingly enough bill and Raul threw
themselves into this wholeheartedly and
for the next seven weeks me and Leonard
stayed at my friend Jane holders in New
York and and we ran up bills at a
dubbing studio and while recutting
okay we're dubbing and this is like I
can't come up with a metaphor but it's
the most ridiculous thing in the world I
mean it's one or the other right and but
it gave an interesting opportunity to do
some rewriting and take a piece here and
a piece there and somehow reshaping and
that radical it's very subtle it's I
always say that it's like it's like a
dew drop on a blade of grass you had one
more BAM blade collapses there was
finding that magical pace and finding
ways around certain dead moments and so
forth there's very very delicate but
that was that was throughout the
throughout the of September and October
and mixed in in New York and in December
and I had a interlock screening here in
Los Angeles in December of with a mixed
track for Suzette cope and he asked to
send a print to Paris to work print
which I did and then we get this
astonishing telex it's on the screen at
one point it's in French but he's saying
it's hard to say he's saying we want to
tell you that you're in competition in
con but with two with two conditions one
will calculate a six cent new fellow and
oh no keep it keep it secret we will
make the announcement at a later date to
everyone here finds that in the second
half of the film in particular there
there yeah yeah a longer there are some
lengthy moments okay which is
astonishing that the you know the
director the most important festival in
the world is going to tell you to to cut
your film but there was something else
you said it was even more interesting
France icon this is this speaks to the
notion of of this film being a tide of
time out of place Conn had a tradition
not not official but an understanding
that each film that's in composition is
from a specific country well this is
from Brazil so French consider Brazil
tropicale yeah you know and there's a
whole language issue so what it says in
the Telex is it's okay for the two main
characters to speak English when they're
alone in the cell but the secondary
characters should all speak Portuguese
and could you please have bill hurt
William Hurt speak with the warden in
Portuguese and either reshoot it or I
don't know I you know I it's kind of
like I'm a Kafka s yes nightmare that I
don't know how I dealt with them so I
can't tell you okay
I don't know blacked it out it's blacked
out Oh considering you went from let's
burn this movie from the lead actor all
the way to you're going to be in
competition I can I
you're allowed to block out some pieces
I blacked out some but that was just the
beginning because ganas may have may
have 85 let's go let's go forward
another
with ten months to march of 86 it was
the first independent film to ever get
the top four nominations so it was a
kind of surreal
well and independent film at that time
didn't even really have that large of an
imprint on the Oscars at all let alone I
mean it was a it was a much different
market oh yeah completely there to try
to explain it giant leap so the giant
leap but it was let's say it was it was
in a an anomaly my definition of
independent for example the year before
Amadeus you know which I Ryan released
and Saul Zaentz had his network of the
best distributors in the world who all
ended up you know so basically you know
that's independent right well that's one
kind of independent this is this is the
independent with not a penny of Industry
money in it and and everything depends
on the goodness of the film as to
whether it will ever be seen none of us
had any expectation that it would be
seen we just had to do it I can't
honestly say that nobody none of us not
one of us had a clue why we were doing
this it was almost like in in in Close
Encounters the third kind you know that
mountain well there's just something
right that's it
no one any any any one of us who says
otherwise
just not true well it was a really
unique convergence of people and a
really amazing accomplishment and I was
happy to have it screen on the big
screen again thank you very much for
sharing not only these photographs but
also your memories of it because well
thank you very much I'm very grateful
for this is Sheree
thank you all for being here I suggest
if you're interested you should check
out his documentary it's really
fantastic and very comprehensive
you also have maintained the collection
of right everything spider-woman yeah
very briefly I have four
unintentionally over the 30 years I kept
every single frame of of outtake trims
out everything not just the Masters that
one normally retains but I wound up
keeping it simply because it was cheaper
to just pay the storage and to put
myself through throwing it out and I
never got a round of it and now it's the
its I believe it's the only fully
preserved 35 millimeter film with every
single element ever both in magnetic
sound 35 millimeter film even even down
to 17.5 magnetic full coat everything
it's six hundred and some-odd boxes and
storage and so my goal is to turn that
into a an installation because it I
would say that maybe in 20 years from
now if we're still around it will be the
dinosaur bones of a hundred years of
what filmmaking was was before Italy
when it was filmmaking when it was film
yeah yeah exactly
well that's terrific I look I hope to
see that installation myself oh I think
you will I hope so and if anyone wants
to watch a documentary thank you very
much for mention that it's called
tangled web the making of kiss of the
Spider Woman
everyone it's like is it's like everyone
tells their story and it's it's very
explicit and it's a it you can find it
on vanishing cinema com so I also hope
that those of you who are enjoying this
series come especially for La Cienega in
two weeks
Lucrecia Martel the director is going to
be here and I think she is an incredibly
singular talent and probably verging on
or taught tourism not a theory I
necessarily subscribe to but she's a
really unique filmmaker her new film is
the Argentinean candidate for foreign
language film I hope you'd come meet her
I think she's a really interesting woman
and we have more throughout this series
of people who will be on
the stage that you may or may not have
heard of and the voices and their
experience will be singular so don't
miss another Monday you guys were the
smart ones here tell your friends thank
you for coming
[Applause]
you
you